tennessee titans had a 10-0 lead and a
17-7 lead in the first half on sunday in
kansas city people were starting to
think maybe the tennessee titans could
actually pull it off get back to the
super bowl for the first time in 20
years it was not to be the titans lose
35-24 and now they have to pick up the
pieces chris and two big questions they
have going forward contractual issues
ryan tannehill the guy who became the
starting quarterback six weeks in and
was great highest passer rating in the
league at 117.5
he's due to be a free agent derek henry
the nfl's leading rusher with 1540 yards
and the first guy in nfl history to have
three straight games with 180 or more
rushing yards he's due to be a free
agent they got some big questions they
have to resolve fairly quickly yeah they
do i mean ryan tannehill they got to
bring him back i mean come on he's he's
part of like the dna of this team right
now he gave the organization a boost
you know you got you got to bring him
back and just see if you can ride this
momentum into the 2020 season derek
henry same thing i mean hey the team is
built around the offensive line in the
run game so i look at that and go yeah
you got to bring him back too and derek
henry for the sledgehammer he is let's
not forget the first two years he played
in the seat in the nfl he didn't get a
lot of wear and tear so this is not a
guy that's like your typical oh going
into year five type running back and
that way where you just go oh wait he's
really beat up they've rode them hard
the last two years especially in the
months of november and december but he
should be somewhat fresh that way so i
think they got to get that done mike i
mean that's the first thing that jumps
out to me and then the other thing that
really jumps out to me on the offensive
side of the ball i think they got talent
in pieces they got it all going but they
got to grow the offense you know i i
think we saw you know just a little bit
of it on sunday again when the run game
didn't work there's just not enough past
past concepts and creativity in the past
game to kind of carry out carry them out
of some of those moments we saw on
sunday and that would be the thing that
i think that the next thing that's
really big for them on the offensive
side of the ball is just expanding the
offense being more creative for when you
do play that team that can slow down
derrick henry and you can't control the
line of scrimmage
yeah i don't disagree with anything you
said however my lingering concern would
be
franchise tag the transition tag
the titans like the buccaneers and the
cowboys may be rooting for no new labor
deal because if there isn't a new labor
deal by the start of the league year you
get one of each a franchise tag and a
transition tag which comes in handy if
you got dak prescott mark cooper or shaq
barrett and jameis winston or in
tennessee ryan tannehill and derek henry
if you ultimately only have one tag to
use on tannehill or henry who do you tag
oh uh
i think you gotta tag uh derek henry
there that's the guy you go with you
know you gotta play the fact that ryan
tannehill is going to want to be back
you know he can't sit there and just go
oh well there's definitely going to be
some team on the market that's going to
want me in paying starting quarterback
money no that's not a guarantee plus you
know you you want to build on something
you built this past year and and
tannehill knows he's kind of carved
himself a little spot within this
organization and there's something to
build on here going forward so i think
you can almost call ryan tannehill's
buffalo bluff a little bit as compared
to derek henry i would franchise derek
henry if it had to come down to one of
the two
i agree with you it's cheaper to
franchise tag and they're gonna have 21
million that flies off the books as well
when marcus mariota walks away but
speaking of quarterbacks so many of them
out there this year supply outweighs
demand and i think the history of ryan
tannehill the concern that maybe it was
just the planets lining up for him and
the injury issues that we saw in the
past i think that that means he's not
going to get the kind of offer that the
titans wouldn't be able to say hey come
on we'll pay you the same stick around
here that's right i just can't imagine
somebody just like blowing the doors off
of ryan tannehill and his agent to where
they're like oh my gosh we can't turn
this down you're right there is a lot of
there's a lot of supply out there this
year between the draft and free agency
when you start to like hammer it out you
go whoa there's some names there to be
had you know i mean uh yeah i mean we
don't even have a guy like andy dalton
on that list right there you know teddy
bridgewater is not on the list as well i
mean there's more names to be thrown
into oh there he is on the list sorry so
there's a lot of names to go around you
know the other thing is too to me let me
let me throw something out i just got an
idea i got an idea right if you're the
titans i mean you can be coy you don't
even have to say uh we don't think
there's going to be anything out there
you can say hey you know what if you're
not going to sign this deal now we're
going to start looking at our options i
mean i see drew brees name on there if
the saints decide to go with taysom hill
and i want to keep playing and i'm drew
brees and nashville isn't all that far
from new orleans and i see i've got
derek henry and i've i've got a defense
that was good enough to get to the nfc
or the afc championship excuse me and
it's you know a division where i think i
can go in and be competitive and tom
brady may not be on the patriots anymore
if i'm drew brees i'm very interested in
that if i'm the titans i don't know drew
brees ryan tannehill which one do you
want well i mean i think ryan tanner has
more potential for the future right now
uh yeah you're right brees might be a
quick fix and certainly be a name and
drive a lot of excitement there
so that is that is interesting but
you're right they can call the bluff of
ryan tannehill and he's got a spot you
know there's just only 31 of them left
in football so you almost sometimes as a
quarterback you just go man i built
something here i got to stay here the
other thing we didn't hit on mike the
titans got to find some pass rushers
like we saw they can't get there with
the front four against kansas city
that'll be a big thing too for them in
the off season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports